[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soleil de la bonne humeur et de belles
voitures des ingrédients qui font bon
ménage ce samedi 17 juin plus de 200
pilotes de voiture de sport et de
collection se sont donnés rendez-vous à
l'occasion d'un rallye caritatif le but
faire profiter les enfants d'un tour en
voiture et collecter des dons en soutien
à l'association imagine formar 2
[Musique]
pour moi radis du cœur c'est une journée
pour que les enfants sans cancer et avec
des cancers en profite pour s'amuser et
oublier leur malchance suite au décès de
sa fille Margaux des suites d'un cancer
à l'âge de 14 ans Patricia blanc fond de
l'association en 2011 pour venir en aide
aux enfants malades depuis imagine form
margot est actif partout en France et
cofinance des programmes de recherche
pour lutter contre les cancers
pédiatriques 11 ans l'association a
donné 17 millions pour la recherche
contrôle cancer des enfants nous avons
mis en œuvre plusieurs programmes de
recherche qu'on a co-financé une
quarantaine de programmes de recherche
et nous aidons aussi nous 400 familles
maintenant dans toute la France redonner
le sourire aux enfants c'est aussi ce à
quoi s’est engagé Alexandre Pacaud comme
les autres pilotes ce passionnait de
voiture à collecter des fonds pour
l'association et emmène Eileen une
bénéficiaire de l'association qu'il
parraine depuis plusieurs années à bord
de sa Porsche pour une virée dans la
vallée de Chevreuse on va rouler sur
environ une 50 60 km pendant une bonne
heure dans des petits villages dans des
petits trous de campagne dans la forêt
pour faire faire un joli petit tour aux
enfants dans nos voitures ce 17 juin
imagine forme Margot a collecté près de
310 000 euros de dons un record pour
l'association
c'est parti
[Musique]